my name is George Motz do you want to be
my friend
[Laughter]
my name is George Motz and it is my job
to preserve hamburger history or cut my
hair okay that wasn't convincing enough
what you may or may not know is that
there are many many regional Styles out
there I've eaten thousands and thousands
of burgers in the last 18 years of
research as you move across America
burger diversity of the house and each
regional burger has a story has a great
piece of history to it there's so much
to know and learn about the American
hamburger out there we're about to go on
a regional adventure ready to cook let's
do it what I get to give to you is my
knowledge of method when hand whoa oh
[ __ ] that come from let's smoke a burger
this will be your deep dive into the
wonderful world of regional hamburgers
I have a ball of beef about time you
cook burgers it's it's it's a lot of
work a whole damn thing goes into the
four oh [ __ ] back the burger scholar
sessions with me George Motz